next question today should illegal
actions as a teenager affect your career
as an adult particularly in the context
of a Supreme Court seat Brett Kavanaugh
or other endeavors in government this is
a you know we I've done my rant for you
before of where not everything is black
and white and the answer to this is it
depends okay I have friends who were
caught shoplifting CDs from a from a CD
store when they were 14 and some of
those friends went on to work in
government at the federal level and they
listed me as a reference and I was
interviewed by an investigator and of
course I had no idea of lying but my
friend said I know you know about the CD
stealing thing you can mention it I've
admitted it it's you know it's not a big
deal clearly that was not something that
should have prevented them from having a
federal job it didn't prevent them from
having a federal job and it's pretty
cut-and-dry Brett Kavanaugh at the age
of what was it 17 I think 17 in one
accusation he was in college for another
accusations let's stick with a 17 year
old one for now at the age of 17 is
accused of having tried to rape a woman
named Christine Blasi Ford should that
have no bearing whatsoever on his being
appointed to life as a Supreme Court
justice even if you want to make the
case that the actions themselves
shouldn't he's been allegedly lying
about them right if the if the
allegations are true he has been lying
about it an adult as an adult and then
it definitely should have repercussions
now now the question would be if he
hadn't lied about it if he had said you
know what I did try to force myself upon
this woman when I was 17 years old I was
a kid I had been drinking which we often
hear I would never do that now I
completely understand why it was wrong I
apologize and I apologize to anyone that
that found my actions deplorable which I
do then maybe you have a conversation
right and you say well 17 you're legally
not an adult but you do certainly know
right from wrong at
at age but you were drinking but
drinking's not an excuse for doing that
then you've got a real conversation on
your hands right the allegations against
Kavanagh as an adult in college I
believe that if they are true there is
no question whatsoever that they should
be disqualifying for his role as an
appointed to life Supreme Court justice
I mean if we're looking to draw a line
here maybe you draw that line when it
becomes violent crime so things like
petty theft
you know shoplifting or drinking
underage even getting a DUI that stuff
can be more easily forgiven than say
rape or you know serious assault that
sort of thing as Brett Kavanaugh is
accused of right so you just wish
between misdemeanor and felony like is
that kind of the distinction you're
drawing I think so yeah but I mean it
gets dicey too because assault could be
considered to teenagers getting into a
fight and that's something that you
would assume you be able to forgive and
that that shouldn't affect their
employment opportunities going forward
wouldn't that be misdemeanor assault in
most places sure yeah yeah I I think
that I'm bringing up misdemeanor versus
felony merely as a thought experiment I
think we can all identify felonies that
we would say that really shouldn't
prevent you from having jobs as an adult
at what if you did that as a kid and
misdemeanors that maybe should because
of their more depraved nature
unfortunately my answer is it depends
and I think that there is no blanket
answer to the question should crimes
committed as a teenager I guess by
teenager we also mean not 18 or 19 right
not legally an adult we mean 13 through
17 the answer is it depends and it also
I hate to break it to you it depends
what job we're talking about right there
is a difference between whether crime a
should prevent you from having job B
versus job C if you're talking about
Supreme Court justice for life
adjudicating all sorts of the most
serious legal questions the crime that
we would say crosses the line might be
different than if you're applying to be
I don't know as somebody at the SEC for
example where Securities and Exchange
Commission that is a government
regulator but is not a Supreme Court
justice it also depends what job you're
trying to get yeah I feel like we're so
uncomfortable with their answer here
because it sounds maybe like we're
trying to have our cake and eat it too
like we can just pick when we don't like
what the person did or like their
politics we say it's too much like bait
or orc when he was young he got arrested
for a DUI now he wants to become a
United States Senator I think that's
something that can be a lot more easily
forgiven than Brett Kavanaugh sexually
assaulting a woman and am I just is that
just because you know I hold these
political beliefs and I'm on the left
and I feel so bad that means that I
accept one and not the other I think
that I hope it's not no I mean it's it's
an interesting question and I don't have
a definitive answer but the world is
messy isn't that what we always go back
to there are not often simple principles
that apply to all situations